as many of you know
Joe Biden was involved in illicit
business dealings overseas
one of those illicit business dealings
was telling the president of Ukraine
that if he didn't fire the prosecutor he
wasn't going to get congressionally
approved loan guarantees and now we know
that there's an FBI informant saying
that Joe Biden is involved in a criminal
bribery scheme well the big news today
the GOP has revealed that this executive
at barisma has 17 recordings of Joe and
Hunter Biden as an insurance policy so
it seems like things are about to get
particularly spicy and I think this is
probably as we enter the political
season it's going to make things bad for
an already ailing president in terms of
his approval rating which is at a an
apocalyptically low rating historically
it's not as bad as Carter but it's the
worst we've seen outside of that for the
most part so we'll talk about that plus
we got some other crazy news in the wake
of this story being published what do we
have we have bongino report we've got
post millennial human events as well as
a few other sites being hit by a major
DDOS Cyber attack that's shutting them
down
so we'll get into all of that stuff and
Donald Trump says that when he's elected
president he is going to send a special
prosecutor after Joe Biden so here we go
it's Tit for Tat It Is
it's on
before we get started my friends head
over to publicsq.com and download the
Public Square app why stop giving your
money to people who hate you and on top
of that stop giving your money to people
who might secretly claim they like you
but would never stand up for you Public
Square is America's Marketplace it's an
app where businesses can list their
business
and they pledge to support American
values so you know that when you
download this app and you pull up the
map you can see all the businesses in
your area that actively support American
values and this is how we build the
parallel economy it's how we push back
against woke corporations and my friends
with apps like Public Square at
publicsq.com we are winning we're seeing
all the big boycotts we're seeing
regular people say enough the
opportunity is now and you can be a part
of it simply by downloading this app and
providing your business to the companies
that don't hate you and actually agree
with you again publicsq.com we're big
fans shout out to Public Square we love
what you guys are doing and uh again
download the app also don't forget to go
to timcast.com click join us because
tonight
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show and if you sign up at
the 10 if you sign up for the 10 a month
level for at least six months and if you
sign up at 25 bucks you will then be
able to ask questions live on the air
with us it's basically a screening
process because we have to have some
kind of screening process so we we
settled on time and or hire money to try
and weed out near to Wells and things
like that but uh we love to to see you
on the members only show and uh
supporting us directly joining us
tonight to talk about all of this and so
much more is Brandon struck what's up
thanks for having me it's good to be
back absolutely who are you I'm doing
great uh I think this is uh my fourth or
fifth time with you yeah good to be back
I said who oh who am I I don't know what
is uh Brendan Schrock founder of the
walkway campaign
um yeah the movement of people walking
away from the Democratic party and walk
away social our app right on thanks for
hanging out and of course Jack besobic
been a minute Tim it's been a minute
Jack besobic the host of human events
senior editor of a website that no one
can get to because we are currently
under what I am told by my Tech Guys a
deliberate attempt to take
downhumanevents.com also uh prior Navy
intelligence officer and I think we
might be talking about a little bit of
how intelligence reporting works today
it seems like the attack on human events
post-modial bongino report a couple
other websites may be related to this
this GOP report about Biden the secret
secret recordings so what I'm told and
I'm I'm just looking because we're in
you know at our highly secured uh you
know highly super secret group chat here
that basically the minute we posted the
minutes we published the report from
this and so people understand this is a
this is an FBI informant file that
grassly read on the floor of the Senate
and when you and Tim I know you know
this that when a sitting member of
Congress or the Senate reads out
something even if it's classified they
cannot be prosecuted for releasing that
because they're doing so on the floor of
the Senate he uses his ability to do
that as a senator to come out and say
that there are 15 recordings with Hunter
Biden and two of Joe Biden when he was
the vice president describing all this
long story short we put out the article
summarizing all of that the whole site
goes down on and so human events owns
post-millennial human events goes down
post millennial goes down we're also
told bongino reporters going down some
of these are coming up there's a few
other sites we try pulling down DC
Enquirer it's one up and down that's
been up and down in binding reports down
but we'll get into it I'm not going to
say the name but I will say that we are
not on Amazon web servers so this is not
Amazon so what we will definitely get
into all that of course Ian's here
what's up everybody Ian crosson happy to
be here let's move it along yeah and I'm
surge.com and uh I think we should just
get started we got a lot to cover let's
get into it we got the story from the
Washington examiner Joe and Hunter Biden
caught on 17 recordings with barisma
owner Grassley reveals FBI form or
Grassley reveals FBI form says I love
that that would be it should be a
semicolon and not a comma after the word
owner right there yeah because so we can
understand the conflict that's
interesting it's not the owner Grassley
is revealing that there is an FBI
informant saying this right and so this
is this is official in Intel in in uh to
the FBI now being released to the public
a top Senate Republican revealed Monday
that an FBI informant said the Ukrainian
oligarch involved an alleged criminal
bribery scheme with Joe and Hunter Biden
also claim to have 17 recordings of his
conversations with the president and his
son Grassley revealed on the senate
floor that a largely unredacted version
of the bureau's FD 1023 confidential
human Source form said that the foreign
National who allegedly bribed Joe and
Hunter Biden allegedly has audio
recordings of his conversations with
them 17 such recordings I want to pause
right now and say okay
the bribery thing is really interesting
but what we can't say for sure is that
Joe Biden admitted publicly on camera
that he threatened to illegally withhold
congressionally approved loan guarantees
to Ukraine unless they fired a
prosecutor as we now know that
prosecutor was investigating barisma so
here we are I guess the uh and correctly
if I'm wrong uh Jack the bribery was
that they went to Joe and said get the
prosecutor fired well and and to be
clear the investigation was so the guy's
name is Nikola slachevsky and he and so
zlichevsky is the oligarch who was in
control of barisma
um
he was under investigation domestically
in Ukraine and by the way yes the same
Ukraine that has the war that's been on
fire that seems like dominates all the
conversation over the last six years
when prior to the last six years I don't
even know the last time any of us even
talked about Ukraine right it Trump's
impeachment the War uh the the coup in
2014 suddenly Ukraine is like everywhere
um
he was under investigation for bribery
inside Ukraine then he goes and hires
Joe Biden which we know publicly he goes
and hires Joe Biden's son Joe Biden gets
the prosecutor fired then he said he's
bribing Joe Biden to stop the guy who
was investigating him for bribery in the
first place
okay okay so zachevsky is the is this
post oligarch that's in control of
barisma yes he he's the guy that hired
Hunter Biden yes and then
um and then he bribed Joe Biden to stop
and vet to get to get a prosecutor fire
to stop investigating his company well
so and according to these reports
um it seems as though the hiring of
Hunter Biden coincided with and again
based on the report I I interviewed
Marjorie Taylor green who has seen a
copy of the report she also gave me some
more information stating that This
Confidential human Source this or CHS as
they say in the parlance is uh someone
who was one of their most highly
credible this is this isn't just some
walk-in some random guy like hey I heard
about uh Joe Biden and the uh you know
by the way so there's there's a whole
process and I remember what even when I
was an Intel agent you know or Intel
officer that there's this question of
how do you know that the source knows
well you're constantly vetting placement
and access you're constantly vetting uh
credibility you can go back and check
you know did a person actually go to
this place where they said they work and
you check can you Geo track them et
cetera et cetera so there's a huge
process that the FBI is running on this
person to make sure that the reports
that they're giving are credible which
by the way could also include recordings
of you know wearing a wire right as we
all know from from movies Etc so the
idea is that this informant is giving
that report to the FBI and saying that
that this hiring of Hunter which we knew
publicly coincided with not one but two
five million dollar payments one two
Hunter Biden and one two the big guy so
these recordings how many are shell
companies how many of the recordings
were Biden and how many uh how many were
Joan how many were Hunter two Joe 1500.
that makes sense to me because you know
Hunter's the one who's actually working
in barisma he's there right probably
having a lot of Converse missions check
this out they say the examiner says
sources previously told the Washington
examiner that the barisma owner
discussed an alleged bribe of 5 million
dollars to Joe Biden and a five million
dollars to Hunter Biden according to the
paid FBI informant who said he heard
this from
the sources said he believed it would be
difficult to unravel the alleged bribery
scheme for at least 10 years because of
the number of bank accounts involved
there's clever ways they can run this
they could do something like look
I've got a company in this country that
runs a couple subsidiaries that harvest
wheat
we'll we'll have those companies hire
you as a consultant through your
investment firm so it looks clean and on
the level that's how they play this game
then you get like multiple bank accounts
involved where money's being transferred
all around and then you've got to prove
the transfers were specifically for the
bribe so it's very difficult unless you
have them on on on audio tape talking
about what they're doing and how they're
doing it well also unless you're the FBI
which literally exists to I mean the FBI
has
agents that are specifically tasked with
working with the U.S treasury Department
to actually go after the and unravel
those very same shell games that you're
talking about and so what's what's so
shocking to me is that we're seeing now
they're even in the report Grassley
alleges that when they first went to the
FBI and asked to see the hunter Biden
file that there were portions that were
redacted relating to these audio files
that the FBI redacted that before they
gave that report to Congress wow so the
FBI was actually trying to now they're
going to claim right of course the FBI
will say well that's because of our
informant that's because it came from
the informant but here's the thing
you you don't need to say that in the
report that it came from an informant
you can just say the FBI has information
and the FBI as we know has multiple ways
of receiving information and so they're
redacting that clearly raises a huge red
flag of all sorts of issues not to
mention separation of powers not to
mention the administrative State versus
the the elected representatives and you
really have to go back and say look I
know a lot of people were
let's say I would try to be nice here
skeptical or at least not sure of Kevin
McCarthy the House GOP in general they
said is are these guys actually going to
do anything are we actually going to get
information out and I would say look I
mean say what you want about you know
certain certain fights certain Hills to
die on Etc that we would not have this
information right now if the boss ends
that right now if the House GOP had not
brought it to us Tim I know you got that
reference
let me uh I wanna I wanna read this this
is a very important paragraph in the
story
Trump and his Republican allies claim
Joe Biden improperly used his position
as vice president to pressure Ukraine to
fire shoken to protect his son from an
investigation into bursma Democrats deny
this and argue the focus on barisma was
part of an effort to dirty up Joe Biden
well hold on everything in that
paragraph is true
well I don't understand
this is the same keep in mind let me
just just to clarify it so when Trump
and other Republicans investigate Joe
Biden for overt and obvious corruption
it does in fact dirty him up in the
election and I'm sure that played a a
played a role in why they would do it
you mean kind of like but all the
resting your leading opponent right
right you know all they're doing is
they're saying Democrats deny it but
argue a part of why they would do it
which okay look if you are running for
office and you find out that your
opponent is a criminal you would
absolutely be like we must defeat this
person because they're a criminal and we
can't let them run this country so yes a
component of what you're doing is we
need to expose the dirt on Joe Biden
it's real
this is the exact same thing that all
the way back in 2019 and all and I've
some of these names maybe not lechevsky
but I think people have probably heard
the name barisma a lot by now and you
know even at a general level these are
the same exact companies and names that
came up in that Infamous perfect phone
call between Trump and Vladimir
zielinski right the same Vladimir
zielinski I got my zielinski shirt on
today
um you know I see you guys aren't
rocking
a little bit you're close but you got
you got your showing the guns off the
whole thing it's like uh but there's
this idea that when Trump was talking to
zielinski and he was asking him hey I've
heard about all of these things I've
been watching the news I've been seeing
that Joe Biden obviously at one point
literally bragged about it on national
TV that he got the guy fired and he's
saying look you're in Ukraine you're the
president of Ukraine could you look into
this could you make a few phone calls
could you see what's going going on they
impeached president Trump for just
asking the question about this right
here which we now know keep in mind Tim
that at the time that they did the
impeachment the FBI had all these
reports on file and not a single one of
them came forward and said well actually
what president Trump is talking about is
something that we have on file
there is a there is a criminal Syndicate
in the government
I mean I don't know how many I don't
know you know but we know that the FBI
is purposefully not Prosecuting certain
individuals and so whoever is
instructing these people to do this is
part of some kind of criminal Syndicate
I'm not trying to make it seem like
there's a network of thousands of people
with initiation or anything like that
I'm saying certain elements of the FBI
the executive branch and the Democratic
party are absolutely subverting the law
in this country in collusion with each
other end of story We There was that you
see that clip out of CNN where the guys
are like Hillary Clinton had the cell
phone smashed with hammers and I think
it was Allison Camerota she's like can
we no no can we get a fact check on that
and the guy goes yes the the Hillary
team did have phones smashed with
hammers and and servers wiped and she's
like oh you mean like with a towel
whoops it is funny when I hear people
say like didn't Hillary Clinton pour
bleach on her computer and it's like oh
geez man like the the bleach boot bleach
bit wasn't it was an app it was a
program to to urge a hard drive which
the guy found on Reddit yeah that was
funny was that what it was well nobody
did he posted saying like I need help to
it and they found his posts on the
subreddit because he's talking about I'm
working for a a very important
individual who really really needs
something deleted it's it's it is crazy
to me that Donald Trump is facing a
Federal indictment despite the fact that
Hillary Clinton did substantially worse
exactly for a fact we know she had
classified documents in her private
server that she kept and it was
destroyed and all of those emails the 30
some plus thousand that we know of were
public records that she destroyed and
nothing happened and she posted that
picture of her hat but her emails and
smiling it's like they broke the law
they got away with it and now that
Trump's getting arrested they want you
to know that they will keep committing
crimes and nothing will be done that's
why I was talking to Jack before the
show and I'm like well what's the next
like what's this long game going to be
are they gonna come out in the media and
be like but you guys Joe Biden had to
get the FI the prosecutor fired
otherwise we wouldn't have had any
protection against Russia when they
invaded Ukraine we all we did all this
manipulation for your own good like
they're just gonna one day just flip the
lights on admit it all and say it was
for your own good and then 90 of the
population will just believe it with
their jaws slack like that's my fear
well you're you're right you're actually
right about that is that's always been
the Playbook when it comes to one of
these things because the first thing the
first time you say it it's well that's
conspiracy that's not happening as as
Tim pointed out that some of them are
actually getting the uh getting it wrong
and they're still pulling that out for
the the email server when actually we've
gone past that one so the first thing
they do is they say it's a conspiracy
then the next thing they do is they say
it's contested then the third thing they
do is they say well this helps
Republicans and that's the only reason
Republicans are going after it for it
and then finally once you've completely
proven something beyond the shadow of a
doubt they'll say well okay it is
happening but it's good it's happening
and it's happening and it's good and
here's why it's good for the country and
everyone that's why it's happening and
how dare you stand against us for
letting this happening so I don't know
if that's exactly the reason they'll
give but I think you're 100 right and
that they will at some point come out
and say you know these payments were
made for the betterment of Ukraine the
security of Ukraine and Hunter Biden was
secretly working on uh you know an
exchange program for uh certain forms of
Ukrainian women on a uh on a uh a need
to know and a special special access uh
Visa you know for the really you know
High Talent people will come to me then
I'm trying to to you know Shadow
campaign this myself in a few months
they'll come to me whenever after this
comes out and they'll be like but Ian it
was good that what they did with with
Biden with the getting the people fire
and I'll be like now I've got to figure
out how to explain to them why it's not
I need to be so laser focused I need to
know Nick Nicholas lachevsky inside and
out Victor shoken inside and out these
names Nikola
yeah you guys maybe like 500 times and
tell you it's like I hear it's like it's
washing over my brain every time Russian
guys uh Ukrainian names uh words like
barisma Victor shoken this
zlachevsky was an oligarch that owned
barisma
correct correct fled the country uh
during these investigations Matt Tybee
reported around a dozen I believe and uh
Biden comes in and gets the prosecutor
fired which was Victor shoken the
problem
signed a sworn affidavit saying that he
was fired because of Joe Biden that the
Ukrainian officials came to him and said
we have no choice Biden said we have to
fire you maybe he swore he swore to this
there's also and and this is coming back
around again that there's audio that was
released by oan years ago
of phone calls between Biden and not
zlichevsky but poroshenko who was the
previous president of Ukraine
petroporoshenko prior to they call them
the chocolate man the Candyman because
he ran a he was like sort of a chocolate
oligarch and he's still around by the
way he's still a member of the um the
parliament there and he's the one who
ran against zelinski in 19. anyway in
those calls at one point poroshenko says
to Biden there is nothing
that we have found that shows that
shoken is corrupt we have no information
that says he's doing anything wrong but
if you want us to do this we will do it
and Biden's pushing him saying we need
to do this and there's a bank and the
kalamoiski's bank needs to be taken care
of et cetera et cetera and what happens
after the prosecutor is fired zlachevski
returns to Ukraine and what happens
after Donald Trump makes the infamous
phone call he flees once again once once
he knows like uh oh uh oh they're gonna
start looking into me again and Joe
Biden was like we got someone in there
who was good
what's the next step there is who's
what did the oligarchs then do so
kalamoisky is the other oligarch who's
working with lejewski at this point is
has the bank is sort of the financial
end if you look at it that way
um he has got the bank
Biden's saying I know this guy you know
he's kind of an a-hole et cetera Etc but
we got to deal with him we got to deal
with him that was the bank that received
the IMF money
so those oligarchs come in and say look
we still got this problem with the
presidency et cetera et cetera whatever
and you know now Trump's in what do we
do so they say what if we can bankroll
our own president here in Ukraine and
that same oligarch ran a TV network and
on that TV network they had a very
popular TV show called servant of the
people all about a teacher like a you
know public school teacher who becomes
essentially becomes the president that
actor
was named Vladimir zielinski and those
oligarchs then decided to put him up and
bankroll him to become the new president
of Ukraine in 2019. did he have any
political Acumen before zielinski no he
was just an actor and they were like
you're good enough he was a comedian and
then an actor and he played the
president on TV and they were like works
right Wow Let's jump to this next story
is it was the same oligarchs that are
being discussed on this phone call with
Biden there is hope my friends we have
this report from timcast.com Trump vows
to appoint special prosecutor to go
after Biden if elected saying now that
the seal is broken in addition to
closing the border and removing all of
the criminal elements that have
illegally invaded our country making
America energy independent and even
dominant again and immediately ending
the war between Russia and Ukraine I
will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president
in the history of the U.S Joe Biden the
entire Biden crime family and all others
involved with production of our
elections borders and Country itself
election interference at a level never
seen before in our country in a
subsequent post so now that we know that
Trump is being charged and the seal has
been broken as you said in more ways
than one seal has been broken well
that's it yeah there there's there's no
way out of it now the next time a
republican gets elected it's going to be
political lawfare 100 percent
and it has to be because you know when
he he kind of campaigned on this whole
Locker up we're going to go after
Hillary Clinton and I think he got
elected and he went for this thing like
let's be compassionate let's unite the
country let's bring people together and
it was a huge mistake I mean look
exactly what they're doing yeah I don't
think I'll make that yeah that's a bad
mistake will be made again
yeah Jack
uh getting a report now from post my
guys opposed Millennial they are saying
the sites are back up they've got all
the information from the bombshell story
that resulted in a DDOS attack
post-millennial human event make sure
you go subscribe by the way to make sure
that we can fend off the next great
opportunity for a plug by the way all
right but yeah we pull up post
millennial quite a bit on the show and
we have Libyan quite a bit so what
happened is before the show I'm like you
know let's see what the post millennial
is on about and it wasn't working and
then Jack's like well we just put out
these big stories and sure enough but uh
back to uh Donald Trump I thought it was
just a resting point and yeah no it was
too big too big but uh Trump's gonna uh
go after Joe Biden so obviously you know
Brandon and I are in agreement Jack I'm
curious what you think
it's gone too far
you know it's it's really gone too far
at this point where you've got a
situation where this this and keep in
mind that it's it's not just if you
think it's just Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden that are taking foreign money in
the United States government you've got
you if you want to be serious about this
and I would say as a way to take this
out of the necessary necessarily like
Left Right dichotomy of it uh you know
Republicans are going to Or democrats
are going to Republicans so so Biden and
all his guys are going after Trump and
they're saying oh you didn't you know
classify you didn't you didn't say it
was Declassified even though he's a
president he has declassification
ability they're going after him for all
this stuff uh that we already know that
Hillary got away with
to take it out of that I would say that
you don't just need the special
prosecutor for Biden I do that obviously
because we've got way too much
information now plus by the way it
apparently there was an investigation
that for whatever reason this level the
highest levels of the FBI are protecting
the bidens even though we know that they
already have this information they had
the information when President Trump was
asking about it they wouldn't give it to
him he goes and asks uh Ukraine about it
because he's like well if I can't get it
from my side I'm going to ask the other
side because he's a problem solver right
you know he's a pragmatic guy
um businessman that we need an entire
commission I think we need a federal
commission about foreign money that's
going in this is something where look if
you are a Bernie Sanders supporter or I
guess these days you would say an RFK
supporter and you are actually concerned
about money and politics wouldn't it be
a massive issue if there were foreign
oligarchs and foreign funds that were
paying into our politics and shouldn't
we know about that and it's probably
worse than just that I mean I'd imagine
the Chinese Communist party is
heavily investing in there you go
political candidates and they can do it
through very special ways they can give
money to a corporation that does as
mentioned you're mentioning mentioning
earlier Dianne Feinstein turned this
into a cottage industry for her and her
husband it's it's not so easy to prove
these things a company that that sells
Sombreros in China sends two million
dollars to a company that you know makes
a specific fiber they use and they say
here's what we do we have that company
double its order so it looks totally
normal then that company there's The
fibering Hires a few Consultants at a
couple hundred thousand dollars who then
hire this plumber and so it all looks
legitimate and how do you know which one
was the bribe they do these things in
Chicago all the time
hey hey you know that contract that's
coming up
get get us that contract for you know
this amount of money and then I'll have
I'll talk to my brother and we'll make
sure that he buys from you next time and
then that's that's Kickbacks that's how
it all works so China can say we're
going to buy X product from your company
so long as X amounts of those dollars go
to this political action committee
through you because we can't legally do
it and no one will be able to prove it
well or or just looking at the Feinstein
situation so
um Senator Feinstein in California was
one so she's she's green energy right
she's she's climate change we have to
protect the environment what did she do
she used legislation and she championed
legislation in this country to prevent
the development of rare Earth elements
within the United States that we are not
going to go after those we are going to
protect them we're going to leave this
this sacred land exactly the way it is
exactly whereas meanwhile what's her
husband doing her husband is being given
deals in China with the exact same
companies that are going after Rare
Earth elements and then purchasing those
resource sources and the mineral rights
all around the world for China how did
they Corner the market they cornered the
Senators first yep
man I oh we're gonna say I was gonna say
Trump's got to arrest all of them this
is my feeling about what Trump's saying
he he's like when I get back into office
I'm gonna arrest them I'm gonna set
things right and what it feels like is a
story of like he came in the first time
he's like all these poisonous snakes I'm
gonna kill all these snakes and and make
it snake and we'll be like we're like
okay good less poisonous snakes he went
in he didn't destroy the snakes and then
he got bit by one and now he's poisoned
and he's like when I get back in I'm
gonna kill all the snakes and you're
like dude relax rest you've been
poisoned like they're already hitting
him with like 70 plus federal felony
charges like dude you're in no position
to run for president because they're
terrified of him I know there's really
in the position I mean he's a position
where they can take him off the ballot
if he's being there's a reason that
nobody else is being targeted like this
I mean I I think that the this the Trump
movement singularly represents the most
viable
anti-establishment movement in this
country and because it became so it
attained critical mass that's the reason
you're seeing this
pathogen-like response to it by the
system that you're seeing you'll see
Republicans and Democrats will link arms
the bushes and the clintons and the
Obamas to go after Trump because they
know that he's the one person that
actually represents a threat to them on
a much grander scale and by the way if
he wasn't leading in all the polls and
but CBS youga have some up what 38
points or something right now it's not
exactly like a pro-trump poll
um he's leading Biden in many national
polls I think if he wasn't leading you
wouldn't see these charges you wouldn't
see anything about him that that would
fit more the hey let's let this guy go
you know out to pasture kind of model
but we think he's too damaged
well I think um not psychologically
mentally anything like that just he's in
a in a legal state right now where he's
gonna have a hard time getting his name
on a ballot like he if they but that's
the point yeah exactly so what do you
mean get his name on the ballot if he
well from what I understand if he's
indicted for federal charges and then
found guilty on any of them they can
take his name off yeah is that not right
well some people are saying that the
indictment States will make moves to
remove his name from the ballot he can
still run he can still be elected he can
pardon himself I don't know if it's true
but people have chatted to us saying
that so
there's two pieces to this
um one is that so the only thing that
can prevent you from being president is
an impeachment like like fully prevent
you from being president is impeachment
it's the only thing you mean conviction
right impeachment and conviction
impeachment and conviction yes a a fully
carried through conviction and
impeachment which has never happened by
the way in U.S history
um that then the other piece of it which
I think is this sort of loophole that
they tried to do this with Margaret
Taylor green and they were attempting to
do with Madison cawthorne done in North
Carolina was this these Civil War era
laws that are on the books in some of
the states that say if you were a member
of an Insurrection that you can no
longer hold office in the United States
and that these laws do apply in these
states they were written obviously for
Confederates
um to say that okay if you had been some
official in the Confederacy now George
has been admitted you know back to the
Union Mississippi et cetera Alabama that
you can't go and run for office again
because you were part of that so what
they're trying to do is apply that so if
and and I believe they will by the way
like this this indictment tomorrow on
Trump
um is not going to be the only one they
are going to continue on with the
indictment in Georgia over you know find
the votes which you know is like just
Trump talking a phone call and then I do
believe that they're going to go after
and and bran obviously you've got more
information on this they're going to
take
those proud boy and oath keeper
indictments for seditious conspiracy and
their gun and Julie Kelly talked about
this as well so you know I'm not going
to say like this isn't 100 my idea that
they're gonna just switch the names for
president Trump because that then and by
the way in a DC District would trigger
those laws in those States and set up a
I mean we're obviously an Uncharted
Territory like massive Uncharted
Territory here in terms of all of these
things but it would set up a huge legal
challenge for him now when they did this
with Marjory Taylor green the judge
basically ruled for her 100 but Marjorie
Taylor green had never been indicted and
convicted of anything that would be
considered an Insurrection in fact up
until this conspiracy case no one had
been charged with anything that would be
considered even close to that and so the
idea being is that is there a
possibility I mean there it's it's some
like insane figment of a blue Anon type
Duran conspiracy but that's literally
how far they're willing to go to try to
stop Trump there's um there's a smaller
story besides proud boys and Oath
Keepers that's already happened that a
lot of people don't know about because
there's not enough reporting on January
6 but uh there's a j6 sir named Coy
Griffin uh he was a city councilman and
yes right in New Mexico and
um he got a misdemeanor charge didn't go
inside the capitol on January 6 and I
really want people to pay attention to
this so if you're watching and listening
look it up and share it
um but he was a city councilman in New
Mexico got a misdemeanor charge for
standing outside the capitol didn't go
inside the building uh but the Democrats
in New Mexico went after him to have
them removed from office for this very
reason and the judge went for it and he
was actually removed from his position
for being involved in Insurrection and
so he's now having to appeal that but
the point is that the president has
already been set we have we have now
removed somebody from office for
Insurrection connected to January 6th so
that's we have precedent for that now
and of course they're going to do that
to Donald Trump I think you're exactly
right I think I think this is what it's
so you know people look at some of these
j6 cases and they'll say okay this is a
one-off this is one of no no they're
building towards this they're building
towards the person the precedent and
they're set they're moving slowly and
slowly and slowly to get to the point
where and by the way this case down in
Miami they know this is a weak case plus
they also know that because of the
district the jury pulled down there
which is an area that almost went for
Trump in 20 that decisively went for um
DeSantis in 22. I mean there you try and
tell me that you're not going to pull 12
people and not at least get a couple of
like based Cuban you know Miami Cuban
guys on there that are like look we we
saw this in communist Cube but we know
exactly what you're doing we're not
going to go along with this you'll see
jury nullification you'll definitely get
a chance of that in DC you never will
not if your name is Donald Trump and
this is the big this is the Big
Challenge the the jurisdictions are
everything the the political and culture
bifurcation in this country is so near
absolute that if
you could have any liberal District just
be like I'm well indict him they can
detect you for anything they some random
liberal District in Washington can
indict anyone and then just you can get
a ham sandwich and then the people in
that district will convict because they
don't care about any kind of
constitution Community or laws they will
just say now you're guilty so that's why
we talk about Trump and these
indictments I'm asking people do you
really think a New York jury is going to
acquit Donald Trump you really think a
DC jury will equip that well he's going
to be in Miami so that's a maybe for
sure right Miami I would say you he's
got a 50 50 chance probably even
stronger than that because there's no
keep in mind that Miami even though
that's where the court is the district
itself is actually bigger than just
Miami Dade County right uh the the
southern district of Florida so you've
got I mean remember we how many people
move down because of kovid Etc we all
know the story right and the trending of
Latinos and the legalized Venezuelans
that have gone there the Cuban so I I
think he stands a pretty strong fight
enchant in that area just based on the
jury pool demographics but look at the
uh the rape Civil Trial in New York you
had a guy on that jury who even said he
had seen a few episodes of timcast still
saying that Donald Trump is responsible
for raping that woman in the most insane
story we've ever heard
so you look at New York and I'm like bro
they're gonna they're gonna convict them
and they're gonna and the judge is going
to say jail time I don't see a scenario
where a judge is like well now hold on
Donald Trump's a good guy so we're not
gonna they're gonna be like lock them up
New York is is a very bad uh uh venue
for Donald Trump but it's not as bad as
DC I don't think and he's actually more
popular in New York than people think
than people I mean it's overwhelmingly
people are against him there but he he's
more popular than people think no I
don't I don't see so first what will
happen is the jurors identities will get
leaked and then the judge will probably
be like who cares something like that
will happen then you're going to hear
story like no juror who is entering the
the courthouse to pass judgment on
Donald Trump to issue a verdict is going
to
whether they like Trump or not I just
don't see it happening the reason that
one guy probably said yeah you know what
Trump is responsible for this is because
they probably said to him listen they're
probably sitting in the in the in the
jury deliberation or whatever room it's
called
and they said I don't know or care about
Donald Trump I don't want Auntie for
throwing bricks at my window exactly
you're guilty yep well that's uh that's
a tampered jury you need it look yeah
how would we expect to have an impartial
trial in this situation because this is
this is the case that that happens when
you have a country that's been so
bifurcated the way we have where our
access to information has totally
changed because of the internet where
and and the rise of cable news that
you've set up a case now where there is
one part so conservatives generally will
say well you know I want to hear the
other side I want to call out we want to
we want to keep everyone on the same
standard we want to make sure that you
know everyone's playing by the rules
where's the left the left will just sit
there and say I want to destroy the
right I want to destroy anyone who's
related Donald Trump who's related to
January 6
um you see case after case after case
that's why they're putting a Bannon on
trial in New York right it wasn't even
in New York but they're gonna on trial
in New York that's why Ben he's got his
four month sentence that might be coming
up soon by the way that's that's already
happened for abandoned that he may have
to serve four months and it's looking
that way
um but you also had to to Brandon's
point there was a case where on that in
that very same so Steve was
uh raising money for this we build the
wall uh Endeavor where it was like this
private building the wall thing and one
of the guys so one of the guys took a a
plea deal uh Steve got pardoned and
there was another guy who actually went
to trials this is the federal case not
the state case there was another guy who
went trial in New York on this and there
was one juror who sat there the entire
time and said you know what you guys are
a bunch of liberals you guys are just
repeating whatever the government tells
you and that you can even see in the
like Politico has the report the man
repeated anti-government conspiracy
theories and through the entire trial
and refused to go along with anything
the other people said so some somebody I
think his name was Roberto uh that
someone actually did get in like a
normal person got onto one of the trials
and stood up to these guys and stood up
yeah or something so it was a hung jury
but that being said not exactly a great
legal strategy if you're if you're
hoping for that but the media also has
got gotten very involved in the justice
system and and I think that there I
wouldn't be surprised if they're
bullying jurors and stuff as well I mean
throughout my j6 criminal case
um I had reporters from CNN contacting
my prosecutors asking them to rethink
giving me a plea deal I'm literally just
inserting themselves into the system
MSNBC had a guy chasing the the Kyle
Rittenhouse jury remember the jury
threatened was going back and then they
lied about it they lied about that it
was happening and they and so MSNBC put
out the statement or and then NBC as
well because it was like he was an NBC
Stringer basically and they said oh we
don't have anyone doing that and then
they found the Purdue and then they
found the guy and said no here's the
producer this I I work for him because
he was you know he wanted to stay out of
jail basically yeah and a hundred
percent that's that's 100 what they do
let's jump into this next story we got
this from timcast.com
the daily wire has received about 200
violations from YouTube regarding
coverage of transgenderism Jeremy boring
quote YouTube only does more damage the
longer it keeps its finger on the scales
Candace Owens and Michael Knowles have
both been suspended for seven days from
Friday well they were they were
suspended completely suspended
completely cannot post videos I didn't
realize that and and well funny enough
no one's writing about it wow yeah if
you look it up it'll just say
demonetized but Jeremy Moore Jeremy
Jeremy boring Jeremy Jeremy says on
Friday Candace Owens and Michael Knowles
were suspended for seven days after
receiving their second strike and Jordan
Peterson was given his first strike
three in 90 days and your account is
terminated I don't think this has
anything to do with the Trans issue to
be completely honest I think what we're
seeing with Fox News with project
Veritas and now the daily wire anybody
who is prominent and vocal and is a
threat to the establishment is starting
to get hit particularly hard kind of
like DDOS attacks over at the
post-millennial and human events where
if you go and subscribe you can help us
prevent but but in all seriousness yes
post-millennial bongino report human
events just got hit as we're preparing
to do this show with a major DDOS attack
this is all coordinated there's no way
look you know we had on
um I think it was John cardello and we
were talking about Veritas and I said I
find it very strange that Fox News and
veritas did basically the same thing to
O'Keefe and Tucker suspend them so they
can't work but don't release them from
their contracts yes so they can't go
anywhere else either that's a very
specific strategy to take against
prominent individuals in the cultural
debate in the culture War as for the
daily wire they're not big Trump guys
you know there many other personnelas
are very much for Ron DeSantis but
either way they're challenging the
cultural establishment the norms and the
Machine and so what they're saying is
that YouTube is actively employs a
YouTuber actively going through year old
videos and issuing strikes and takedowns
four posts that they had no problem with
before wait so this isn't like this
isn't like the daily wire and I'm sorry
I haven't read the story but this isn't
like the daily wire launched some new
campaign that broke all the rules it's
that the rules have actually shifted and
they're going retroactively yes against
old videos that were okay which by the
way YouTube recently changed the rules
regarding elections so there was there
was a certain topic that we could only
talk about here on in the third hour
which we could now talk about on the
radio show that's actually not
necessarily true we I I talked with
Steve Bannon about the election issue
and he outright said he thought the
election was stolen they just had this
weird rule that I think only applied to
YouTube's rules only apply to their
actual targets and the rules are
arbitrary is the easiest way to put it I
mean that's what I'm getting at the when
when uh the hill I think it was the hill
Rising I I believe uh with uh Sagar and
crystal ball soccer and Jetty and
crystal ball they had a clip I think it
was them I could be wrong they had a
clip of Donald Trump at a rally because
they don't do it anymore and then Donald
Trump at the rallies at the election was
stolen and YouTube took their video down
there were also like news reports that
where they did the same thing but then
you had David Pacman who had on Mike
Lindell and David allowed Mike Lindell
to say
his entire theory of how the election
was stolen and I asked YouTube why is it
that David Pacman can host Mike Lindell
and say Mike tell us all tell us
everything and then he does but then you
take down a clip from a rally that was
on the news of Donald Trump saying a
thing it's because the rules were
arbitrary as they are now YouTube didn't
change the rules on transgenders and
they're changing their interpretation of
what breaks the rules that's what
they're doing so if you know Matt Walsh
or Michael Knowles and Michael Knowles
especially makes a very simple and
academic argument about his views on
transgenderism or something like that
they that they'll say okay well that
didn't cross the line
year later you know what nah it did boom
because what is hate speech it's
interpretable there's no clearly defined
line that you can or cannot cross it's
just uh you're against at Sunset speech
take you down I think this is a lot to
do with the election cyclist here don't
be surprised if they start coming at us
in some way somehow whatever that may be
they're already coming after you whoever
who and I'm talking about and we're
gonna literally we're going to dig into
this I'm talking about super pac's
political interests uh hackers probably
Rogue elements of the Intel agencies
we've already seen by uh foreign States
foreign States I mean if Ukraine's
involved in this obviously they don't
want these tapes coming out
have you not experienced the retroactive
your episode Brandon there was that the
episode
a bunch of times with walk away
I wasn't on that episode what happened
yeah don't know the app the the last
time you were here we we did an episode
and one of the clips was was removed and
your full episode was removed I believe
the clip came from the full episode and
we got an email from YouTube saying we
know that you didn't intend to break the
rules but you did so we were moving
these videos but not applying a strike
to your channel and then the video was
taken down wait wait have you seen have
you seen what Darren Beatty's been
talking about about his clips from from
here
so IRL from IRL where and I'd have to go
back and look exactly what it was but
they he had a clip from IRL from like
forever ago talking about Ray apps like
I mean easily over 18 months ago where
you could go on Twitter and I tried this
and you were clicking on it and it
wouldn't play on Twitter on Twitter so
it was a clip from IRL on Twitter and it
was like and I tried on multiple devices
I try to unlike you know on Wi-Fi off
Wi-Fi it would not like it would start
and then it wouldn't and then it would
just go to the spin and it would lock I
think yeah so it was taken down too
which one I think that Darren Beatty
episode was had been taken down by well
we we we took it down to put it on
Rumble and it's actually our most viewed
episode ever well yeah it's got like
eight or nine million views crazy uh
I'll tell you crazy stories drives in
effect in I think it was 2017 I could be
wrong I went to Davos
during the world economic Forum I was in
the peripheral events crypto was a big
component so flew out and I was like all
right recorded some I think I was only
doing like one video per day at that
time so I like recorded a video in
advance flew to Davos
three days of videos that I produced
there are gone oh wow no idea how or why
never received a message or a notice
just on my youtube.com timcast Channel
you can go to the date and there was a I
discovered this years later
when there was a specific video I made
about the case for Bitcoin coming out of
Davos and how all of these you know
worldly Elite types were very interested
in crypto and I was like I want to find
that video that I did because I
interviewed somebody in a bar gone and I
was like where are where are my videos
they're just gone I used to think this
is this has happened a couple times
another time was I produced a video on
something called the install woman you
ever hear the story
woman in Norway and Bergen Norway it was
a woman who was found up in the
mountains just outside of outside of the
town of Bergen uh the city and she was
dead they said from smoke inhalation
they found a bunch of passports or
something the working theory is that she
was massage and she was tracking down
former Nazis and ending their existence
but this time she did not succeed don't
know for sure exactly if that's true
it's a mystery everyone wonders what
it's all about okay that video is gone
now that one I I can't tell you why and
you know I I thought it was a cool
little mystery ghost story like 10
minute thing and one day I went to to
find it and share with somebody gone
the Davos thing I wonder if that one's a
little on the nose here I am in the
peripheral I didn't go in the event I
had no access to any of that stuff but
outside of the world economic Forum a
bunch of people show up and put on
peripheral parties and events because
they want to basically like suckle the
teeth of influence because everyone's
there yeah and they're hoping that their
peripheral event will get attention and
so I'm there I put three videos together
as I was doing daily videos and they
just got erased
so I'll just put it this way YouTube
very much so secretly takes videos down
there's an individual who is a
whistleblower they called him for the
CIA which resulted in Trump's
impeachment and I don't even know the
rules on saying this guy's name anymore
but you did say I did say his name
nothing happened yeah maybe maybe that's
why they're they got met but these
videos have also been taken down without
notice Carrick aramella yeah Carrick
Carrick aramella yes good old Derek
there was a period where even though his
name was being reported widely in the
Press yeah you can say it Rand Paul's
right speaking on the senate floor
unrelated issue mention the guy's name
from a report and YouTube deleted a
C-SPAN clip Fox news clip as well they
were taking this down and they had no
justification there was no rule of
violation it is obvious that there are
intelligence agency assets interlinked
with YouTube the same as Twitter and
Facebook and we know it
we know who's really behind all this Tim
Santa Claus they yeah I was watching
Justice League it was them again I was
watching them I was watching Justice
League and it's this really funny clip I
I started laughing super hard it's the
shows from 2005 but it's Superman being
you know Shazam uh Captain Marvel quits
the team and then Superman's like he's
right and then Batman goes they set you
up Clark and he goes what does it matter
anyway they and then he goes they and
then it plays ominous music and it shows
all the like Justice League looking at
each other it's funny because they is a
reference to the powerful establishment
the corporate Elites the wealthy Elites
but the media for some reason has been
desperate to turn it into specifically
Jewish people so it's like when we when
when we say colloquially they they will
try to claim you're talking about it's
like I'm usually talking about like oil
companies and and Banks you know well
it's contextual as well like right for
example you were just talking about
Davos so in this case you'd obviously be
referring to the world economic Forum
having some kind of joint at the hip
behind the scenes relationship with the
leaders of YouTube so it makes sense for
you to say they and that's well no I
don't think well because it's so much
longer to be able to say that I think
intelligence agencies I think we'll talk
about the the Davos clip specifically I
still think that's U.S intelligence
agencies I will say that I know for a
fact the U.S intelligence agencies have
been very very interested in Bitcoin and
continue to be from from even back when
I was still surveying to way into the
future and I had interviewed some
prominent figures in the political space
and without warning without a strike
without an email the videos were taken
down so I wonder if they were like yo we
don't want that person on camera they
shouldn't have done that what do we do
well the video's been publicly viewed by
50 000 people
if we give a strike it's going to make
some waves and we don't want it to
happen so just wait a little bit remove
it without saying anything and it's gone
that's a great it's like stealth editing
yep going into and so with the thousands
of videos we've produced the thousands
of videos daily wire I bet daily wire
doesn't even know the videos that were
taken down because how long how often
are you going back you know or are you
looking at your total number of videos I
mean it's just you know you're you're
churning out content constantly you're
not like sitting there looking at hey
I'm missing five videos you know yeah I
think the daily wire guy this thing is
like personal uh after like what was a
month ago Matt Walsh got demonetized and
then they went we're officially going to
Twitter I think Matt wall show is not
officially on Twitter that is what the
home of the Matt Walsh show so people at
Google understand the people with daily
wire have no loyalty to Google and
they're like all right these guys are on
their way out anyway I mean you're
seeing and that there that is a broader
story right so you are seeing right now
a broader Showdown because Elon has
certainly been making some
overtures suggesting that he might get
into the online video
uh Market Marketplace that he might get
into this Periscope they're talking
about bringing that back he's looking at
different ways to monetize uh Twitter so
if Twitter video people posting Twitter
could potentially be something but also
YouTube is is facing a ton of
competition for rumble right now and
they're starting to feel the heat
they're absolutely starting to get to
eat I mean it's crazy when you look at
some of these Rumble videos and they
have massive viewership thousands of
live viewers yeah tens of thousands of
views per video and even the videos we
put up get decent amount of hits in the
tens of thousands and that's something
we've not seen any rival be able to pull
off until now we've um so we just on on
human events so we just took my Daily
Show and we were switched it to a live
format in the afternoon now 2 p.m hey
check it out and we we noticed
immediately like a tenfold increase in
our Rumble numbers just overnight
um the people love it they say like it's
it's a little bit more in the mix you
know it's live so people like that
format but suddenly all of a sudden and
I think Rumble it's you know you know
and look like you know I mean I love the
guys at Rumble but I'm sure that they
are giving more priority to live video
because they realize that's a capability
they have that they need to have if they
want to compete against YouTube twitch
Etc everything that's out there yeah if
you make internet videos that you should
probably be backing them up on across
multiple platforms I used to think like
all my stuff's on YouTube it's safe now
in 10 minutes
yeah unfortunately well especially after
going back and taking you know old
content down for for new rules you know
as they become more insane the things
that you made years ago maybe violating
things that they've now decided uh
you're not allowed to say yep and
they'll retroactively give you a strike
and delete your channel it's insane
which and guess what you know Elon Musk
came to swing in and buy every platform
out there I mean I wish but no it's not
gonna happen the strike thing feels very
weird that they struck the channel for
something that happened a while ago yeah
well the strikes we don't I don't know
where the strikes came from but so 200
violations and I think let me put the
thread from Jeremy what did he say over
the last few months what will happen is
as a social media admin if you see an
account that's questionable and you're
like I think this violates terms but
it's not overt so I'm not gonna block
this thing because you err on the side
of like let it up let it stay up and
then it but it builds and then you'll
start to have this like inventory of
like disputable content from this one
Creator and they'll have like seven
things that they've done where you're
like these are seven questionable things
and then over and over and then all of a
sudden they'll do one that crosses the
line you're like all right all of them
cross the line now so not really an
ethical way to do it but that is what
happens it does seem like a good portion
of them are demonetization violations
and so we've gotten our share of those
too
uh I I I I I don't think I've gotten
um any hate speech demonetizations it's
usually like graphic it's like oh we
demonetize it because it's adult content
or something it's like showing violence
or or conflict or adult themes
but not for hateful derogative
derogatory content like they're going
after uh the daily wire we're pretty
religious about not doing that on this
show I mean we will talk with our guests
before we go live about what not to say
what violates YouTube's terms so
everyone's up to speed and we got like a
99 accuracy right that's absolutely not
true Ian on on this show we we may be
mentioned maybe we may be mentioned to
like one out of 15 guests what YouTube's
rules are which results I want to think
it's more than that yeah and that's why
we end up having to take episodes down
because people think that they they
think this show is like sitting in your
friend's living room having a beer as
opposed to Prime Time cable TV talk or
something like that so I usually tell
people if it does so we used to have a
card that's it like this is what
YouTube's rules are we don't have rules
YouTube does if you want to say these
things and the show gets taken down
understand that's what will happen and
so I try to I try to I try to keep a
bounce to it where I'm like I'll tell
people look and you can say whatever you
want if you've come all the way out here
to come on this show and then you want
to say things you know will break the
rules we'll roll our eyes and then the
episode gets taken down so if you don't
care about people seeing the episode
like totally get it
but we stopped showing people YouTube's
rules because they would then
intentionally break them or just only
talk about that and we were like dude we
showed you the YouTube policies not so
that you could sit here and just only
talk about that or to intentionally try
and break the rules so then we're like
okay just like dude don't make allusions
to violence all right and then YouTube
had a rule about the election whatever
in fact most of those rules you're
they're not actually enforceable as long
as it's a debate and not overt
but the reason I push back in because
it's actually very very frustrating that
we don't tell everybody when they come
on what YouTube's rules are and then we
end up having to take episodes down lest
we get suspended for a week yeah
sometimes you'll go three hour or two
hours I guess we do two hours in an hour
and 59 minutes of it is totally cool but
30 seconds go by and something gets said
and you're like well that's that's we
were batting 99.98 but you can't trim
episodes you can't trim things out I
don't know why they took your episode
down that we did Brandon no idea they
did not tell me we talked about trans
stuff a lot that night yeah but but
we're not like
you know the one thing I tell people is
try to keep it academic yeah you know
what I mean make make your your
criticisms Fierce and passionate but you
know make them academic and not just
generally trying to insult somebody and
so we're usually fine about it and I
have no idea
sorry to interrupt what is their policy
about uh misgendering I don't think
there is one that you don't no because I
remember we talked a lot about Dylan
Mulvaney in that episode and you were
you know staunchly arguing that he's a
man and we were kind of like having that
discussion and my position has been on
all these episodes we'll see if they
write directly enforce this is that
Dylan is a character like Borat
intentionally insulting women and trans
people yeah and now Dylan has that
statement saying I want to move Beyond
this and be a comedian yeah like it's
very it's very lesbian it's very that's
an old part of this comedy and and
actually that clip was him saying that
he's attracted to uh trans women not
biological females sorry but the clip
was was was was cut off what he was what
Mulvaney was arguing uh to his dad was
that he's attracted to women and his dad
was like oh wow and he was like no trans
women because trans women are women
that's what he was saying not that he
likes females but uh my position has
always been that Mulvaney is in I
believe it's a character intending to
mock trans people like would you guys
find like some some
like Paparazzi was like filing following
around Dil Mulvaney and then found that
you know like a normal life like he
doesn't dress like that or act like that
at all but I don't I don't I don't
necessarily care to get into all that I
will just say that I'm saying it goes to
your point he's playing Camp that's how
he described it like he's campy you know
yeah and you look at like Borat as Bruno
yeah was like a fake gay guy and being
over the top and insulting and you know
Ron Paul got really mad about it that
that that's what I see with Mulvaney but
uh so your episode gets taken down and
we have no idea why they won't tell us I
bet that's part of it because that was
right when the Bud Light uh boycott was
kicking off hard and there's a lot of
people talking about Dylan and a lot of
videos got pulled over the course like a
week period or something yeah including
something I think by Michael Knowles
there's something interesting too when
it comes to like Fox News and other
cable networks I have never been told
one time I can't say a thing like
they've never even said hey remember no
swearing I've never even told that
you know you go on you you I don't know
if you've ever you you've done TV hits
and stuff I'd imagine both you guys a
lot yeah have they ever told you like
okay now don't forget when you're on
this is FCC Airwaves so you can't say
these things yeah I've never had that
happen no and Fox Nation you can swear
but the cable network you can't yeah
yeah I've never had someone sit me down
and say anything like that I mean
typically you know you'll be told like
this is what we're going to discuss in
the hit we want to bring you on about
um uh like you know like when I put my
antifa book out there so you know a lot
of TV hits for that so you're gonna talk
with antifa about this you're going to
talk about this this is the flow it's
this long it's never anything about that
they're never like don't say the f word
tonight no yeah we always tell people
like we try not to swear if you do No
One's Gonna cry about it but there might
be kids listening and they go oh I guess
realistically the onus is on you to
understand FCC regulations if you're
gonna go do a show an FCC guided show
you really are supposed to know
otherwise you're not going to get
welcome back I was on uh Glenn Beck's
radio show and I said dick I said I was
being a dick and then he was like just a
reminder one FCC Airwaves but you know
anyway and I'm like well radios there
they're a huge yeah can you not say dick
like I I didn't say like male generals I
said like I was being a dick
it's the word literally in that context
means a rude person you know and a few
people have it crossed the line on on
air on Fox and that's been awkward and
those people have not been asked back
there have been a few moments like that
didn't they but have happened who who
was uh
no Matt Walsh or was it was it Matt
Walsh
who was like they stopped booking him
after he he said something on the air oh
yeah yeah he called uh uh he said he
said that um Grant tunberg was
developmentally disabled is that what
happened but that's true
I mean she like she's Autistic or
something and I think he he referenced
this some factual statement and they're
like don't say that about her and it's
like he's like I still remember a couple
years ago when Newt Gingrich was on and
he was talking about the DA's and this
again this was like 2020 and he's
mentioned and oh by the way you have a
lot of these left-wing DA's in big
cities that were funded by George Soros
and the host Cuts him off it's like whoa
whoa we don't want to go there we don't
want to we didn't bring that up and he's
like what do you mean he's the one who's
funding them like I didn't
but it was um yeah he gets cut off the
interview gets stopped he gets like told
off on air and and it's what's Wild
though and you were talking about how
the rules change from day to day now
everybody talks about that it's totally
fine people push up Rhonda sanus talks
about it and he's like a he talks about
Ron and Sanders talks about it Harris
Faulkner constantly okay and
and he's like you know a major candidate
right not not like the leading candidate
but a major candidate and I've never
heard anyone push back on DeSantis to
call him anti-semitic for bringing up
George Soros because I think we've we've
we've breached a point where people
realize that you know now former you
know retired George Soros it's just so
obvious and it's so heavily reported
that you just can't talk about the issue
without referring to Soros DA's it's
just true it's true true exactly so I
think it's a great example of showing
that if you keep pushing and you have
the truth on your side right that's the
other part of it you can't just keep
pushing you know for fun remember uh
that you're gonna win remember when a
bunch of people were claiming that there
was like an elite cabal who was
trafficking miners
you know powerful political and
corporate Elites and the media was like
you are crazy you people are nuts and
then Epstein got arrested for it and
then Maxwell's in prison for it and it
was true and Instagram had a massive
Network that was rolled up which which
by the way is amazing to me that we had
this we have this news that comes out
Instagram has this huge pedophile
Network that it's totally available it's
promoted by the algorithm you've got the
Stanford internet research Observatory
you've got
um the University of Massachusetts of
Amherst that puts all do you see have
you seen this thing it's in the Wall
Street Journal they came out and they
were they came up with
they're basically these like dummy
accounts like a brand new account for
Instagram and they would make the
account look like in some instances
they'd make it look like just a general
account and sometimes they'd make the
account look like it that the account
itself was of a minor and then they
would go and interact with accounts that
were offering and they use lots of
different uh
euphemisms and code words for pedophilic
activity child sex child sex trafficking
child trading in some cases menus of
things that you could order specifically
from these accounts and then the next
time they went into Instagram the out
and you went into the search function
the algorithm was feeding it to them yep
wowing it back to them hashtags Etc but
what's Wild to me Wall Street Journal
drops that story and it's just like
everybody kind of shrugs their shoulders
goes on to the next thing like there's
there's massive pedophile networks
operating in the open in the clear on
Instagram they're using all the code
words some quite Infamous and and nobody
has anything about it we don't even talk
about it but the corporate narrative is
Donald Trump should be arrested Hillary
Clinton did because it came out on the
same day that the news dropped about
Trump's indictment let's jump to this
next story from timcast.com Fox News
sends Tucker Carlson cease and desist
letter over Twitter show oh boy I love
this totally insane they say Carlson was
abruptly pulled off the air by Fox News
in April as we know axios obtained a
copy of the Season assist letter which
they report said not for publication
quote Fox is continuing to pay Carlson
and maintains that his contract keeps
his content exclusive to Fox through
December 31st 2024 very very interesting
timing the report exclaimed Carlson is
making a First Amendment argument for
posting on Twitter and asserts that fox
has committed material breaches of his
contract yo they are trying to silence
Tucker until the election is over they
want they want him in golden handcuffs
and they used to do this they many
networks have done this
in fact I think it was genk yuger who
talked about it when he was at MSNBC
they basically give you no air time but
they're paying you so you're in golden
handcuffs they take care of you and you
can't work that's what they were trying
to do with Tucker hey look we're not
running your show anymore but we're
going to keep paying you and he's like
no I want to speak out I think the
machine the corporate Elites the neolibs
the neocons no
it was uh what year was it was it 2018
when uh Alex Jones and a bunch of uh
right-wing personalities were were
suspended across all these different
platforms yeah 18. 18. it was like a big
Purge because they were like hey wait a
minute these are the people that helped
Donald Trump get elected they're going
to be doing the exact same thing and
it's begun not just the daily wire but
also Tucker Carlson
the idea that you would take Tucker who
is someone that think of it right up
until just a few weeks ago right one
month ago the number one name in America
in terms of Primetime news after Tim
cast IRL uh at least I'm certainly not
on on cable news right 10 times bigger
the number one guy the number one guy
and suddenly he's summarily fired but
not only is he fired and in and I I'm
just going to say it in a very
disrespectful way the way they treated
Tucker
um his very last appearance he says
we'll see you on Monday so he didn't
they didn't even give him the
opportunity to do a sort of sign off
show or even come out over the weekend
and say hey this thing happened et
cetera et cetera no and if it was part
of the Dominion lawsuit that means they
knew in advance they were planning on
taking Tucker off the air and did not
let him know at all right yeah I guess
they didn't fire him I'm still trying to
get the Liturgy they did not they took a
show off the air but he's still under
contract so they're basically saying you
you can't work anywhere but don't worry
we'll pay you which is the same thing
they did to James the same thing James
will keep yeah I I wonder if Tucker's
show was part of his contract like we're
going to pay you for this show we'll
give you this amount of money so if the
show is removed from the contract
essentially the contract becomes null
and void probably kind of what Tucker is
thinking legally I don't know I feel
like if someone's willing to take a
bunch of money for a long-term contract
that's the price you pay when they
sideline you you're stuck you lost your
first amendment we're like you can speak
out but there's consequences in in the
form of getting sued by the person you
you signed the devil's contract with so
I don't know like the logical part of my
brain is like Tucker you're stuck tuck
you're stuck no he's not you like the
idea that he can't post videos to
twitter is absurd well that's how I was
going to ask the cease and desist is
just that he's speaking at all right is
that the idea you can't yeah there's not
a thing so they're gonna say
um you know and I'll I'll play The
Devils out you have to be able to give
both sides even argument so I disagree
but here's what they'll say they'll
argue that even though he's not
broadcasting on cable news that he is
essentially continuing his show and
thereby competing with it with what
previously would have been his time slot
so uh the idea is that you can't
continue the Tucker Carlson show or
anything that's similar to the Tucker
Carlson show while you were still on
contract with us so if you change the
format you think it would work like if
he had two guests in like a different
angle I don't no I don't think it's
necessarily the format it's the fact
that he's making this type of content at
all yeah so if he set up like you know
um like Tim like your daily show like if
he was doing like those types of Clips
which is kind of similar to what he's
doing anyway yeah
um they would still say that he's in
breach that's wild man that's
informational content making a 10 second
internet video like this is these are
contracts that were created before
social media existed they don't have any
place in the modern Market where you can
make a tweet make a five second 30 30
minute video when you're sitting on the
each I don't understand
it so then I guess the question would be
what if he was live streaming it just
directly from his phone right to Twitter
that is that the same thing where it's
hey I'm Tucker Carlson and I'm uh
talking about Trump's indictment boy
that was terrible and my country's gonna
have a civil war and you know Etc would
that be necessarily a violation because
I mean they'll argue they'll argue
whatever he does is
but none of it is but more importantly
notice that I I'm giving the argument
from how they would how they're going to
argue it in court they would argue that
him filming live streaming it is the
same thing as a show at Night Live show
right I think they would as well but
he's not going to have to deal with this
they're not going to court they're not
going to assume him he because Tucker
could just be like oh you're suing me
okay I guess I agree with your lawsuit
let's go to Discovery I won't challenge
it for dismissal we'll straight to
Discovery and fox gonna go no wait don't
because then all the all the Dominion
stuff comes out and they don't want that
to happen and he said already that there
have been mem board members of fox who
by the way I'm sure are going to come up
for deposition if this goes to any type
of lawsuit that he's going to say all
right you you who else was in the room
who else was in the room okay you you
and you we're all gonna sit down and
we're all going to find out exactly what
went down when you decided to summarily
pull the plug on the Tucker Carlson show
is Fox News the fox Corporation
right so they actually divested from uh
the the larger Fox that Disney bought
right so it was fun I yeah I think
foxcore for Fox News Corp yeah I have to
wonder then if the stock price drops
in response to the firing of Tucker
Carlson if the board can then be sued
for a breach of fiduciary duty class
action does he not have the option
though to just get out of his contract
and not be paid I thought he I had read
somewhere that he had the option to
cancel his contract I don't think so and
based on my experience having similar
contracts from these networks you can't
you have to request they that like there
should be like a mutual break you can't
the purpose of the contract is so you
can't leave
otherwise there's no reason for them to
have a contract with you right
they say we want you to be only with us
for this amount of time you say yes and
they say we'll pay you x amount of
dollars if they break the contract they
have to pay him out for the full terms
and then he's free to go so he's making
that argument that they've breached a
contract and I say it's kind of obvious
they did which is what happened to Megan
Kelly at NBC yeah and they let her go
no they fired her but then she went in
and got the full remainder of her
contract so she got paid and she got
loose to go do her own thing right away
immediately right but that's because she
was fired over the black it was like a
black face she said I don't understand
why it's offensive people all the time
and it's like she didn't even say
anything offensive she was just like I
don't get it can someone explain to me
and they're like you're fired right
but honestly like that's like Morning
Show banter kind of stuff that you would
do you know maybe like maybe because a
very smart individual I'm sure she knows
what white people don't like it look she
made it like a bandit it was a big
mistake for her to try and do one of
these hokey morning shows her her
podcast now is substantially better and
successful I've I've always said
um you know and and and people know Meg
Kelly and I have had our differences but
uh I vote I mean Kelly File was
fantastic when she was just the you know
the hard-nosed legally goal slicing and
dice in these cases and I think that's
where her podcast has gotten to at this
point and it's substantially better and
let's not forget she's the one who asked
Trump that faithful question about
calling them in fat pigs that's right
and then we got that magical basically
won him the election I gotta say I don't
know Megan personally that one thing
yeah I felt like she had a great kind of
evolution similar to Tucker Carlson
because I remember her being a sort of
neocon in like 2007. if I remember
correctly I remember not liking her at
all being like she's just a Warhawk
she's just parroting the mainstream
media narrative it's so annoying and
then all of a sudden like 2013-14 she
was like not hip to the crap and I
started to see her wake up and kind of
like separate herself from the pack and
and think critically and I haven't
really followed her work a lot but I
really appreciate that Evolution our
podcast is great it's very good I think
this is just the beginning we are going
to see a wave of censorship we're going
to see insane smears lies cheating
stealing you name it my favorite is when
they did that Stanford study on like
people spreading election disinformation
or misinformation or whatever they put
me on there and then you have like I'm
not gonna say these people's names but
there's one woman who claims that I
pushed the big lie about Trump's
election narrative which literally I've
never done and was heavily criticized
for doing it but they've run uh ads to
generate donations claiming that I
claimed since the beginning that Donald
Trump actually won the election and he
was cheated which I've I never said I
said he lost because they were ballot
harvesting and because people were fed
up but they'll lie doesn't matter if it
makes them money if it wins them
elections they'll say whatever so I hope
you all are ready
I'm as ready as I can be man deep fakes
I am never really ready for the Deep
fake until I see it and then I'm like is
this happening we've had the first uh
political
campaign official deep fake act and
DeSantis of all people earlier this week
but that being said this is why if you
remember a couple of months ago I was
pushing deep fakes hard I was like
throwing them up once a week right and I
didn't know it would be DeSantis but I
knew that there would be campaigns that
start slipping them in that just very
sneak sneakily start slipping in these
deep fakes in addition to actual content
but you posted stuff like here's what
would happen or something like that like
here's here's I couched it I always
couched it and they uh I think was the
RNC did an ad of what the future might
look what the future will be under Biden
well this goes back to LBJ it shows uh
deep fake images AI generated images of
Biden in situations that are clearly not
real and are explained as fiction as the
premise of the video right the DeSantis
campaign put real life Trump in big
block letters and then showed three fake
photos of Trump hugging and kissing Dr
fauci but they were spliced in in so
like you know you'd call like a six-pack
right so there were three real pictures
yeah of trump and fauci spliced in with
three fake pictures and I saw
I saw the detainer's campaign saying oh
well Trump post memes all the time Trump
post stuff uh no they called it whatever
they called it deep fakes too and then
someone shared Ron writing a rhinoceros
and I'm like sorry you believed that was
real which actually was a Photoshop
um it was even signed it was obviously
it wasn't epic but the point is is that
no one was claiming it was real and it
wasn't slipped in you know mixed in real
and fake images together was real and
tagged is real right dude that that I'm
sorry like I don't care people are
people are tweeting at me and they're
they're commenting and they're being
like you don't care about when Trump did
the AI deep fake of of this Twitter
space and I was like oh I'm sorry you
thought the devil the devil and the
Hitler and the Hitler and yeah uh George
Soros were all on a on a Twitter yeah
and and Cheney Dick Cheney I'm sorry you
believed that was real like dude I don't
care you're not going to try to it's the
stupidest thing well how come you're not
criticizing Donald Trump when he does it
shut your mouth criticizing Donald Trump
when he posts stupid memes that no one
thing oh Ron writing a rhinoceros yo a
political campaign tagged real-life
Trump and put deep fake images to smear
a political rival there is nothing you
are going to say to me that's going to
make me think otherwise on my opinion
desantises he needs to come out and
disavow 100 percent
I would even go as far as say he should
probably fire whoever's behind that
outright and I don't want any excuses or
a minute or oh here's this here's the
mail room guy no I want to know who's
actually the person who made the video I
want to know who's behind the post of
that they should be fired there is
nothing right outside of that that would
get me to support Rhonda Sanders in any
capacity even if he becomes the GOP
nominee I'm I don't care I think that so
is and just just to tease it out so are
you saying that the intent matters here
right because you think they were
actually intending to
you know trick the audience into
thinking that those were real images
they wrote real life Trump in big block
letters and put it over fake images sure
because those images so if you try and
do a Google reverse on them nothing else
comes up of course so the argument that
they accidentally stumbled upon them no
they put fake images of trump hugging
and kissing fauci because in my based on
what I see and what I believe they were
intending to manipulate people into
thinking Trump actually hugged and
kissed about you and you know what I had
just said that day before I discovered
because the video was a few a few days
older than when I made a video about it
that um
I had stated fauci is Trump's biggest
weakness and DeSantis absolutely could
go after that because Trump repeatedly
said like oh I couldn't fire him or
something like that but then they decide
to cross the line they were the first to
decide we will use AI generated images
that the average person probably won't
notice but we'll see Trump hugging and
kissing fauci yeah sorry dude so what if
if Ron supports that and does not take
action against the person who does that
I do not trust Rhonda Santos so what if
they had just taken let's say one
picture because to your point they've
made it a very strong point they say why
didn't Trump sideline this guy why did
he stand why did he do what he did and
people have gone back and even CNN has
looked and said like well he did
critically here whatever yeah they're
using it as an attack angle or attack
Vector on Trump uh they're using you to
attack him from the right because
they're in a primary they're trying to
get some uh increase in the polls
everybody gets why they're doing it they
deserve to lose and so here's my point
though what if they had just posted one
of the images by itself without the rest
of that advertisement or those texts
would you be okay with that if they
posted a picture on Twitter of just the
Deep fake yeah if they said something
like this is how we see it I'd roll my
eyes and be like guys you're getting
you're on the line man but to take three
caveat if they had caveat in some way it
was it's clear that you've got people
who are coming up to the line and then
like trying to see if they can get past
it posting a deep fake as a gag
totally fine so in the context of being
like Trump is Buddy Buddy with fauci and
this is how we see it I'd be like that's
kind of dirty
but I wouldn't be I'd probably forget
about it right away to produce an ad
where you write real life Trump and then
show it very briefly very quickly along
with real images the intent is is is is
is is palpable it's it's Matt it's
visible
if they just posted a single image you
could be like oh look that text is fake
the White House emblem says it's not a
real have whims it said those aren't
words it's gibberish you could see that
right because like for some reason AI
cannot get text right well because it's
it's text is code it's like writing
meaning into images it can get sure
imagine that something like the like the
alphabet in the English language could
be they should work on that pretty
easily programmed in by putting three
fake along with three real the average
person who sees these smaller images
with real life Trump written over it is
not going to have and it's a video the
time to deeply analyze each photo as if
they if they were if they were just a
tweet at one fake photo people would
notice it was a deep fake right away I'd
still say it's fairly dirty but I would
not be as upset the fact that they
tagged it real life put it next to real
images in an attempt to trick people
into thinking Trump actually did these
things is the dirtiest Politics the
dirtiest Joe Biden launched his
presidential campaign with the very fine
people hoax I will not stand for that
nor will I stand for the DeSantis
campaign doing similar things I think
the verifying people hoax was worse
because he made this big video
explaining the lie and this was a brief
bit of fake news they produced but the
idea that someone's going to come to me
and be like you're you're a Trumper
because Donald Trump posted a meme and
that's why descendants is allowed to do
it shut up don't care literally just
don't care uh if Rhonda Santos at this
at this if he does not deal with it if
he does not address it if he does not
take action against it and he becomes a
GOP nominee I will not vote for him
it was posted by the DeSantis War Room
Twitter page and I don't know how
Christina that's bashaw's thing that's a
rapid response well we don't know who
made it we don't know who made the video
but I don't know yeah I mean it's a
campaign account right but I don't think
you can determine specifically just to
be fair like I don't know exactly who
made it I'm just looking to find it I
can't I'm having a hard time finding it
do you remember what day it went up
maybe a couple of days ago yeah I I
can't uh uh there's there's literally
nothing that will get me behind that I
wouldn't vote for Joe Biden for a
variety of the same reasons the dude's
absolutely corrupt but there is there
there's a line as far as I'm concerned I
complain all day about the media lying
about everything non-stop now I can
certainly complain that Donald Trump is
a dick and he's mean and he's nasty and
he posted that image of alleged that he
says Ron with like young women or
whatever and they try and put an angle
on it I'm like dude that's dirty
politics I think it's disgusting that is
not Trump AI generating a fake picture
to of Ronda Sanders with with young
women that is someone else posted an
image and trump re-truthed it or
whatever and I'm like
that's Trump calling people fat pigs and
being kind of nasty well you know what
are you gonna do about it that's who he
is if you don't like it absolutely fine
I have ragged on Trump's potty mouth
quite a bit but Trump did not AI
generate a fake image of DeSantis to
trick people into thinking descendants
actually did a thing he made he reposted
silly photoshops of Ron DeSantis writing
his favorite animal a rhinoceros he's
very very silly nobody thought it was
real oh no run was waiting Rhino I'm not
going to vote for him nah nah I don't
care yeah it's definitely still up it
was posted on June 5th it's still up
does it and does it have a community
note yes I believe it does it does not
on their page if I click on it correctly
really it does not really because I
remember after I made a video about it
it said at 25 no yes it's not there and
no Community note
hit a hit refresh just sometimes
sometimes I've noticed that if I pull up
a tweet and it does it'll look like it
doesn't have a community note then and
if I hit refresh then I'll be able to
see it nope did not come up with a
refresh it'd be cool if I could turn
Community notes on when uh real life
Trump with some fake life images are you
logged in yeah into Twitter it says real
life Trump on it yeah
um wow
I don't uh I don't see any I don't see
it the santus war room where is the June
5th it's oh June 5th I'm I'm waiting
yeah that was a long day seven days ago
it did have one before though
it definitely had a community note on it
on Twitter what do you guys think of
community notes
I used to I mean I like the original
Community note which was called a reply
you know I voted reply you know like
I'll put a replies it'd be fine with
well the but an upvote on Twitter is a
retweet right so or just engagement in
general yeah so wait something that gets
up up weighted on Twitter has more
engagement so if if you post something
in the comments that's got you know a
picture or a link or whatever it is in
my case it does have a community note
yeah mine does not that is weird the
video contains real imagery interspersed
with AI generated imagery of trump
hugging and kissing fauci without noting
they are fake in addition Trump could
not directly fire Dr fauci without the
move going through the administrative
judge or a late EO what the so right and
so this is a fair point Trump could not
just fire fauci he could have sidelined
him he could have done things but he
even says he like the left would have
gone crazy he was worried of political
backlash well and and keep in mind to
the left but I'm sorry what happened
when Trump fired Comey right is that he
turned into a community
special wanting to know he that's what
started the special counsel of Mueller
investigation against him for two years
because he fired firing of Comey dude
they they still have the fake tweet up
like the DeSantis worm has not even
taken down the the lies and the fake
news that they have made there's look
there's nothing more deeply offensive to
me than someone intentionally trying to
trick people for power
and I I'm sorry dude those actually look
pretty good to be they're well made
they're really now there is something
funny about this top left image not not
just the mahap wems on the on the White
House emblem but that Trump's arm is his
right arm is I believe three times
longer than his left if you've noticed
you see Trump's hand going around fact
she's back yeah but that's because he
plays golf that would mean that Trump's
right arm is double or triple the length
of his left arm
so that's how you know that these are
these are AI generated and you can also
tell it looks like the one at the bottom
middle the AI took Trump hugging the
flag
and then
they took that as like a template or
something
I'm sorry dude this is the dirtiest
thing that I've I've seen in a long time
and uh did not expect the to Santa's
campaign to not only not only space yeah
it's like he's like he's it's he's more
than happy he's like he's like getting
turned on and they're they're heavily
ratioed on the tweet and they have not
deleted it they have not addressed it
nor apologized for it and I will tell
you the longer they ignore it the
angrier I become at them
so if Rhonda santis is going to ignore
this if Christina peshaw and Jeremy
Redford are going to ignore this then I
have absolutely no problem saying if Ron
DeSantis is the GOP nominee I am voting
libertarian wow yeah I like how you said
it's like the dirtiest thing you've seen
in a while I I because it's evil yeah
it's relative like it's the dirtiest
thing I've seen from Ron's Camp I didn't
think of him as a guy that was gonna
throw mud
that's part of his um you know being
evil
I mean it's it's part of his um argument
against Trump it's it's remember so
we're going to separate trumpism from
Trump because Trump has as you were
saying earlier Trump has baggage uh you
know he's he's got a potty mouth he does
things that are that cross the line and
yet so if if you're setting it setting
yourself up though in in wrestling you
would say baby face versus Heel they say
Trump's a heel but descendence is baby
face so we're running his baby face so
if you're running as a face
you can't do stuff that crosses the line
because otherwise bets would you be
considered a Healer I will I will take
the Arrogant loudmouth
dick standing on stage calling people
fat pigs but at least telling you like
excuse me excuse me only Rosie O'Donnell
only Rosie O'Donnell Rosie Trump has
lied about stupid things and it's
usually about his ego or he fluffs
things and he's any and he exaggerates
things if the Trump campaign produces AI
deep fakes directly from Trump and his
in his in his uh rapid response director
I'll say the same thing about him I'm
not playing these games they lied about
Trump non-stop all day every day they
fake impeached him twice they try to
convict him they're trying to arrest him
now in completely bogus garbage I am
sick of it and so after dealing with
years of the democratic establishment
constantly lying to my face and telling
me that I am dumb as they come and I
better believe their stupid garbage
because and you know this Brandon there
was a period where I I don't think I was
ever uh as as like you were a Democrat
right you were more I was kind of like
well you know this Russia thing maybe
let's take a look at the other evidence
and then when it all comes out I'm like
how dare you have have lied to me so
aggressively and you saw it that was
your story you want to explain my story
yeah just yeah I mean for me it was it
was the media um and it was the the kind
of pivotal moment for me was I voted for
Hillary Clinton in 2016 and in January
2017 right around the time he was about
to take office and I was outraged I
posted something about how I would never
be able to understand how anyone could
vote for a man who mocked a reporter's
disability in front of a cheering crowd
and then that was when somebody pointed
out to me for the first time sent me a
YouTube video entitled debunking the
Trump mock the disabled reporter it was
literally the first time in my life that
it even dawned on me that the media that
I trusted like CNN MSNBC Etc was capable
of completely creating a false narrative
and a line spinning a moment out of
context because the whole thing about
the disabled reporter was that this is a
bit that he does all the time when he's
imitating anybody
yeah because because they're caught in a
lie or doing something
has done effectively what my biggest
complaint about the Democrats in the
media is Right generated fake and this
is this is more egregious than just
twisting context it's one thing to be
like Donald Trump said something
offensive and you're like oh come on
show us the quote it wasn't that bad
it's another thing to AI generate fake
images put real life Trump over it slap
it on Twitter leave it up address it in
no way despite all the complaints about
it showing us that the Santa's campaign
would absolutely use the tactics of the
Democrats and the corporate
establishment and they're unwilling to
apologize they shouldn't have done in
the first place but this is the most
offensive thing you could have done
the subject matter is pretty bad too
because if you if you look across the
Magna movement people who maybe loved
Trump and now they're not so sure if
they love Trump and maybe they're
thinking about DeSantis this is going to
be the deciding thing it's vaccines it's
vouchy it's all that so this is like a
key issue for people in the Magna
movement who might move away from Trump
so they're not just lying and
manipulating any random campaign issue
it's the campaign issue that would sway
people over to descendants it's not just
a joke right it's not something like
it's not it's not Trump writing a pig I
don't know right you know it's material
and this this to me and by the way and
I've I've thrown this challenge out
there for De Santa supporters show me
one video so they make this line out
there they say they say well I would
have he and and so to stand is out there
today going after Trump's judicial picks
on the Supreme Court uh coming out
against them and then immediately what
does the Trump campaign do they came
back and they find the official
statements from Ron DeSantis supporting
those judicial picks at the time so what
I always say about there on the phone on
the faucy stuff which by the way totally
cool you said this guy was too close to
faucy blah blah blah listen to it all
right agreed can you show me though like
if you're gonna make the historical
argument can you show me one instance of
Ron DeSantis calling to fire fauci in
2020. during the same time period that
he's talking about he said I would have
done this well yeah that's easy to say I
would have done that years later can you
find any instance of showing that you
would have actually been willing to go
after this issue in the time when it was
actually pertinent because if you can't
then and and which if you've gone to and
CNN's done this and the Trump campaign
did this that he was saying the exact
same things that Trump was saying about
fauci at the same time frame so that's
what gets me about all of this and if
you like I'm I'm fine if you want to
support DeSantis right I'm not like oh
my God how dare you right but at the
same time just don't Gaslight me do not
Gaslight me don't lie to me do not piss
on my foot and tell me it's raining you
know I but I had argued a year ago that
I was for DeSantis over Trump 100
because DeSantis was like a sane version
of trump for the average person that he
lives in without trouble right he had he
had the tact he had leadership
and then
earlier this year I said I don't think
DeSantis will actually go in and
schedule that fire everybody like Trump
is and that's basically the only thing I
think we need right now the most
important thing actually the only the
most important thing we do right now is
termination of these bureaucrats of
these government officials who are the
the you know and you're the only the
permanent government you're the only
person who can do that is a guy who
doesn't have to worry about reelection
right and it's not just that it's Trump
Wants Revenge and so my attitude was
like Perfect Storm my attitude earlier
in the year was like look if potatoes
wins will be happy and we'll definitely
like I will vote for him I think most of
us would and we'll be like okay you know
this is what I won't dude no way like I
am so
what what angers me more than anything
was the constant lies from the media it
wasn't just the stop making me defend
Trump Trope it was the stop treating me
like I'm a and that you can trick
me and the DeSantis campaign just did it
and not only that they won't apologize
for it they won't take it down and the
Santa supporters are insulting me for
criticizing it well have they would I
mean I assume you've invited them on
yeah uh in the past they've said they'd
make time they'd figure it out and uh
and you know we've talked uh about
trying to get this at some point
um I'd absolutely love to have any one
of them on and the first thing we'll do
is ask them why they did it and then
have them address it and uh if they want
to come on this show they can sit down
go into their Twitter and then
screenshot it delete it post the
screenshot and say we DP we've deleted
this tweet we apologize for making it we
have removed the video because it was
wrong to do in the first place if they
want to come on the show they can do
that
otherwise dude I like Dave Smith I like
the libertarian party I don't think it's
realistic I don't think they'll win I do
think if you got a Dave Smith or whoever
ends up running for libertarian party
into government they'd fire a lot more
people than Trump probably would it's
just not real well what if my choice is
between sorry if my choice is between
liars cheaters and manipulators and
liars cheaters and manipulators I don't
know I don't know what to say I mean my
I get yeah to my point on that with with
Trump is people say like oh why didn't
you do this why didn't he do that why
didn't it it's like guys grow up just
grow up for a second right this is the
first time you had someone in government
that was even willing to entertain
discussion of those things and now
suddenly you're going to turn around and
argue that why didn't you drain all of
the swamp right it's no this is the
first time you've actually had a
situation with a critical mass movement
behind him to actually achieve these
things and if you want somebody that to
take this wrecking ball as you're
talking about actually do schedule F if
you put someone in there who's worried
about re-election who's worried about
being investigated who's worrying about
being smeared about who's got to worry
about all these different things I
guarantee you they are not going to
anybody right are not going to be
willing to do what has to be done
because they're going to be so worried
about the next four years agree and if
they're willing to make fake images to
trick you do you really believe that
they're going to fire anybody if they
claim they will to your point it's not
it's not that they it's not that they
want to trick you it's that they want to
get elected yeah so putting the election
ahead they're already doing it they're
both at the election Point ahead of the
principal so they'll come out and
they'll be like if you elect me I'm
gonna fire these bureaucrats no you
won't you're lying get out of here you
you're you're deep fake DeSantis you you
make fake images try and get me to vote
for it's not happening look man I think
DeSantis definitely had more attack than
Trump he didn't have the Charisma that's
fine and we ragged on him for it but
this is this is this it's it's different
I did not vote in uh 2012 I did not vote
in 2016. I barely like 2020 was me
looking at the Trump Administration and
being like yo the foreign policy was
that was that was mainly at the foreign
policy stuff I thought the school choice
was good the no wokeness in Government
Contracting I'm like this is all stuff
we need I don't actually believe
DeSantis at this point if if if they're
gonna run with this you know my first
thought was that after covering and
talking about the story they would take
it down and say we shouldn't have done
that and it's been a week and they've
done nothing so I I'm not convinced that
these are people of good moral standing
I think these are these are power angry
people I can't speak for Ron I don't
know but I think the people around him
are just that's it it feels the DeSantis
campaign feels very manufactured to me
because when he had an opportunity I
don't know six months ago to come out
and announce everyone's like I think
it's the Santa is going to announce
weeks went by months went by no no
mention of it it's similar Joe Biden
like running for office in 2020 he
didn't even run for president until the
very end all of a sudden he appears out
of nowhere it's like other people around
him told him like I feel like people
pressured Ron oh so much like you gotta
do it you gotta do it you got to do it
he's finally it's not that he wants to
it's that he's wanted to so here he is
we gotta go to super chats we are way
late I'll be super clear about this just
to respond to what you said and people
were like oh but so big you're just a
trump chill or it's like look
I think Rhonda Sanders will make a great
present one day I do but why squabble
over four years when you could put
together a plan for 12. right wouldn't
that be the Strategic pick right there
to say you do the four years endorse
then get the endorsement on the back end
everybody moves together so you've got
four years then four years then four
more years and a VP I'd have said that
before this deep fake thing we'll see
but let's go to super chats all right
I'm not your buddy guy says James Comey
gave up their hand when he went on CNN
or MSNBC and said that Trump cannot win
and paints Trump coming back vengeful
ready to clean house
interesting he sounded terrified I saw
that clip is it Donald Trump gets in
here why he could be coming after all of
us that Comey actually saying that like
yes Raymond g Stanley Jr says who's this
young guy and what have you done with
Tim Tate had a good point from pbd
interview there's more of us than them
so it's all about how much we'll
tolerate I agree and our tolerance is
waning that's really it man you see this
Call of Duty stuff Nick Merks Tim the
tattoo oh yeah disrespect these are like
modern celebrities high profile internet
personalities
famous to the point where they had you
could play as them in the game Tim the
tatman says take me off this game if
you're doing this to my buddy and they
were like oh okay I guess they're
reeling from it and the funny thing is
after uh Nick said leave the kids alone
and they they all attacked him for it
and they pulled his uh skin off his his
but it is funny all the news reports no
no but I want to point out all the news
reports Tim all the news reports say uh
Activision removes uh Tim the tat man's
skin after and he's like screamed his
gaming removes his skin him alive uh no
I forgot I was gonna say I don't know oh
yeah they doubled down they posted a pro
Pride uh tweet got ratio to posted
another one and locked comments so but
but I think no I just think I think it
shows that we're winning I was gonna say
if you're allowing Pro Pride skins in
Call of Duty which is a game where the
players kill each other then does that
mean yeah
I understand just saying red failed you
can do that you can't offend them right
right Redfield says Public Square
installed thank you oh no we're we are
big fans of Public Square oh yeah
parallel economy
La Revolution
culturelle Avec Jan rashidi I don't
speak French properly but love from
Quebec before the stream is shut down I
work for a French Canadian Independent
Media called Lux media say Civil War Tim
drink one shot ha ha good luck good sir
good luck
what do we got trash penises how is what
Hunter and Joe done not high treason
we're at the brink of War because of
them and they're clearly not loyal to
our Republic the Ukraine stuff might
actually be treason so so bribery is
actually delineated as an impeachable
offense in the Constitution it is so
everybody knows that the constitution
says High crimes and misdemeanors right
but right before that they s the
founding fathers in the original
Constitution 1789 uh into 1791 actually
wrote out that bribery of the presidency
is and it is one of the direct
impeachable offense like you must
impeach if you have evidence of this wow
David Murdock uh art says special thanks
to Mr strzok without him drag the dead
may have never been never found its walk
away hero Zane dimash to battle through
the Pearl clutching zombie apocalypse
game is done awaiting the okay from
Steam hashtag counterculture drag the
dead interesting cool
people should take a look uh jadavs is
trying to get pedantic he says Tim did
you share fake news calling a one foot
nollie 360 quote nollie cab on purpose a
version of a typo in the title
ah ah my my child let me explain to you
the etymology of the nollie cab if those
are not familiar there's a maneuver that
was invented a long time ago in
skateboarding called the caballerial it
is a fakie 360 it's a fakie backside
360. what that means is fakie means
you're writing backwards backside means
your spin is with your back
towards the front so if you have your
left foot forward it's clockwise
and uh 360 is a 300 degree spin the
reason why some people take issue is
that I did a one foot nollie 360. I
posted on Instagram I put nollie cab and
people said that's not a real thing you
can't call it that because a caballerial
is fakie
the reason this emerged the phrase and
alicab is because in playing a game of
skate which is where your opponent does
a trick then you have to do the same
trick and if they mess up then you do
the trick you get letters it's basically
the game of horse
someone would do what is called a nollie
frontside 360. but if you don't know a
person's stance whether they are left
foot forward or right foot forward it
looks the same as a caballerial so
somebody would say all right your turn
is your trick the person would do a
nollie 360 and they would go uh was that
a cab and they would go nolli nollie cab
that's where the phrase comes from so
yes it is an appropriate colloquial term
in skateboarding but a lot of nitpickers
and skateboarding are like that's not a
real trick and this has been your
skateboarding history with Tim Poole
uh anyway
Aaron says Bill Barr knew the entire
time yep sure did did nothing about it
isn't it amazing
no he I mean Bill Barr a lot of these
guys they're institutionalists right
they exist to I mean keep my bill bar is
the same guy who raised money to defend
the sniper from uh Ruby Ridge
same guy
so these guys exist to hold up the
institution well Trump hired him fix the
credibility of the institution and not
actually go after these types of crimes
oh we have another correction Kaiser
outdoor says it's a nollie backside 360
Tim you're also incorrect when riding
nollie front side remains front side
when writing fakie it inverts so sorry
sir you are wrong
see it like you know my view of
skateboarding is I have like a very
logical mind and so I I like the
structure in my mind is very
mathematical not just there's a lot of
people who skate and the way they
explain it it's more feels no I'm all
math so like the structure and the logic
of the system has to make sense like the
arc an architect architect versus a
gardener that's right yeah or the
architect versus the engineer
the architect will draw the draw the
schematics of what I want to look like
and the engineer goes I will figure it
out right like how am I gonna get that
thing to do that you know
let's grab some more real super chats
and I'll stop talking about
skateboarding
what do we got net next the Slayer says
would you kindly make a full video on
the history of the bide investigation
around barisma then link it somewhere
conspicuous for easy reference I know
you've done it before but Rumble and
YouTube searches pull up nonsense yeah I
wonder if Hannah Claire would want to do
something like that like a 10 minute
breakdown explainer of the whole barisma
Scandal and just like a mini dock
explain that here's the company started
here's what was involved it was a CIA
director on the board it wasn't just
Hunter uh Hunter Biden over black yeah
so kofer black was his name
so yeah you gotta wonder about all this
plus you got to cut a turkey pipeline
you've got the gas prom gas Monopoly I
mean the thing goes deeper than and and
honestly it could all go back and the
fact that barisma is a gas company by
the way I think should not Escape
everyone's notice
yep
what do we got
Von sinful says good news on the culture
front and if you like Comics rip averse
is it rip reverse Isom number two
pre-order campaign launched today and is
already over 700 000 wow Eric July man
killing it absolutely amazing cool
let's grab some more
Seth
Bale uh bail RG on does any pronounce it
hey Tim and gang Valerian hey Tim and
gang I'm a history buff and it feels
like we're living in similar times
pre-World War one but feels like the
American Civil War and the Next Great
War will happen at the same time
thoughts agreed
yeah if there was an American Civil War
that would be part of a World War well
if you actually look at World War One
um from Russia's perspective so Russia
gets involved in World War one but then
experiences a civil war internally which
was uh fanned and supported by the
Germans
um sending Lenin and this you know the
infamous train into uh St Petersburg in
the Moscow in order to knock Russia out
of the war so if we were to enter
directly into an actual War right now
this would be the perfect opportunity
for one of America's adversaries to then
go in and start inflaming that point to
where we actually break out into it so I
mean this is It's been followed exactly
and you look at the Neo Bolsheviks of
today and the Bolsheviks of that time go
read Always With Honor by pyoto Rangel
the best book on this subject whatsoever
yeah watch out for people making the
American military industrial complex the
villain I'm not full on board like Yay
American Military District but they they
use the Russian Emperor as the villain
for to get their cultural revolution
over if they're going to try and make
the war machine the villain to create
some cultural revolution that could
create something much worse so don't
fall for that Cassandra Fairbanks wrote
an obituary for Ted Kaczynski and uh
there's a whole bunch of stuff this guy
wrote about how the left if given
control of Technology will use it to
oppress people and he very much
explained well that's crazy yeah I mean
the dude was was crazy sorry like he he
sent bombs to people like that's that's
there's you're nuts Ted Kaczynski he
just passed away didn't he right yeah
Unabomber he was also one of the early
subjects in MK Ultra that's right yup
very very creepy and weird around 17. I
think it was stick sex and Hammer who
made a really great point and he said
just because someone may be a bad person
with bad ideas does not mean other ideas
they have that are good are bad
so Ted Kaczynski saying that the right
will do things that are bad here's what
they'll do the left will do things that
are bad here's what they'll do it's like
those are really good points from a very
bad person and sometimes really great
people will have horrendous ideas
so follow people blindly ever yeah
uchala says on Joe Rogan Theo Von talked
about having year-old episodes with RFK
Jr taken down in the last couple of
weeks he had no idea why
they're on the interesting um earlier
about Kaczynski uh how many people did
was Nelson Mandela responsible for
killing when he was endorsing and
supporting terrorist activity go look up
uh necklacing in South Africa did you
see uh well Norm McDonald uh has that
funny joke he says you know I was
looking through history and I was
reading that the good guys won every war
the good guys won every war that's
actually a really great way of putting
it yeah that dude was a genius rest in
peace
where are we at
Joshua Guthrie says wife just had a baby
and listening to the show
I hope you are there with your wife
having the baby
just happened
it's like your wife's in labor and
you're like gotta gotta put on Tim cast
well it's like Mozart but now it's what
he says wife had a baby and listened to
the show it sounds like his wife is in
labor and like put on Tim cast can't
miss it posters on
he's got to do the promo code he's got
to do the promo which one uh Tanya is
that whoa
Tanya does not exist Mister where you're
talking about The Fakes you're bringing
up promo codes that definitely 100 do
not exist and only the most
despicable vile people would degenerate
even using false promos t-a-n-y-a yeah
t-a-n-y-a make sure it's it's not oh
it's Tanya polar I says Tim you're angry
at DeSantis for using a deep fake to
show Trump hugging fauci the other day
but if Trump and others even the left
started start using deep fakes to smear
others would you still to cry Ron why
why would I not my anger over making
fake images to trick people into giving
up their rights in their power doesn't
end or doesn't end when other people
start doing it it's like oh look there's
groomers in that school what's that
there's other groomers guess I don't
care anymore that literally makes no
sense if Trump started doing it I would
I will say the same thing
if the left with the left always does it
that's what they do deep fakes I believe
the first ever done was was Ron DeSantis
his campaign but uh the Democrats have
been lying about everything they even
lie about Trump lying about everything
it's hilarious they're like did you know
that Trump lied about this and I'm like
oh what did he say and then they lie
about what he said and I'm like you
never said that you're lying it's it's
insane I know dude I mean they have an
entire indictment that doesn't even
mention the fact that the president is
allowed to declassify whatever he wants
or that you know Hillary Clinton did
this and we all complained about it and
they ignored it but she was never
present that's my point no right right
what I'm saying is that what she did was
was no question worse she did not have
plenary classification Powers she just
had public records on privates on a
private server that she had destroyed
which at one point were being emailed to
her by uh Jake Sullivan who is the
current national security advisor right
now under Biden and these people are
evil man
she'd fire so many emails over to Jake
Sullivan I just they're classified it's
it is not hypocrisy it's hierarchy what
people like about Trump what I like
about Trump is that for all for all of
his you know kind of brash attitude he
just says it when he goes in the famous
moment when he goes in front of the
helicopter he's the White House and he's
like we gotta we got a tremendous deal
we're selling weapons to Saudi Arabia
we're gonna make a lot of money and all
the left was just like he he just
admitted it he just admitted what the US
does sending weapons to these foreign
countries to make money it's like yes
when when the the Syria thing when he
was like we're getting our troops out
but we're going to keep a little bit in
there for the oil because we want their
oil you know it's just like he's
he's just admitting what we're doing
right it's amazing
it The Intercept called him the most
honest and dishonest president we've
ever had because he lies about seemingly
inane things that are related to his ego
but tells the truth about the horrible
things the country has been doing we're
not you know NATO is not paying it's
fair share and you know all of that
stuff the Border four years of Peace of
prosperity baby but then you ask them
about like
you know his golden toilet or something
and he's going to tell you that he's the
best and his house has all of these you
know golden toilets or whatever I'm
kidding about Golden toilets but I mean
figuratively if you ask him about his
status or stature he'll he'll be
hyperbolic because he can he'll
exaggerate because he wants to be big
but then I'll just tell you exactly what
the US is doing
they did not like that
he was the first person on the
Republican side to come out against the
Iraq War yeah and he just outright said
your brother lied to us and I was
watching
it was uncomfortable watching Jeb Bush
in that moment because Jeb was just like
like he went into the crumple Zone he
was right he actually it was like an
accordion just squeezing out like please
he was like please stop he's like please
stop do it because he knew there was no
response you know there's no response
you know there is a way to do the police
clap without being cringy right I mean
there was a way to tell people to clap
without going please clap you do the
hands you go come on everybody let's go
you know if you like nobody would have
would have said anything if Jeb said
something something that's good right
come on you agree everyone would have
just clapped and cheered instead he goes
please clap well this just happened in
Oklahoma with um with Governor Stitt at
the the oh really did a police clap he
didn't do it Billy's clap but he's he he
kind of did you know go back to
wrestling it's like the promo so he does
the promo for DeSantis and says if you
have a clip it'll it'll make more sense
but he goes he goes and we all like
Governor Ron DeSantis and there's that
there's that pregnant pause and nobody
does anything and then he goes can I get
an amen not everybody's tears but that
was better it was better than the police
cop right it was definitely that
pregnant pause where and and whatever
I'll be fair right maybe they didn't
know they were supposed to like maybe
they thought he was going to keep going
or something whatever but he was clearly
looking for an Applause line right and
didn't get one so then he goes can I get
an amen
sh-22 says deep fakes can go one of two
ways political cartoon funnies or
intentional manipulation of the truth I
think that's right when people made fake
images of trump fighting with cops and
being arrested I thought it was funny
like dude Trump was not arrested the
images were clearly fake you could tell
it was silly and people were like can't
wait to see something like this happen
and we know we're getting dangerously
close but like come on it's not real
well he did attack his own Secret
Service agents and take over the
presidential the Beast and drive up onto
the steps of the U.S Capitol directly
targeting Nancy I remember and that's
and that's exactly what I'm talking
about they lied it's just the LIE is
insane I I think wasn't Trump not even
in that vehicle the time isn't an SUV or
something or no no the motor he was in
the motorcade and and there's there's a
barrier between him as a driver
obviously it's
Jason Hutchinson says Jazz Jennings in
Florida bothers me more than political
smear in campaigns that was another
thing that the Santa's campaign tried
brushing off and ignoring when I was
like where's Rhonda Sanders on this you
know what I think
Jennings is uh was uh transitioned from
uh boy to girl
prepubescent and then underwent
um full surgery full sex change
operation at 17 and then I believe at
the age of 20 Jazz posted an Instagram
in Florida saying getting another
surgery and this was during the DeSantis
Administration
and so I there's a video that went viral
of what clearly shows child abuse
happening to Jazz as a child and Jazz
being depressed and you know people are
like this is we need help we need child
protective services Now jazz is an adult
so I don't know what you do there oh I
think I remember this because because
they're older now yeah and I said I said
is this is all happening in Florida
question mark where's Rhonda Santos and
then Rhonda Santos's campaign people
started attacking me insulting me and
saying Ron doesn't have a time machine
and can't go back in time to stop this
from happening and then a bunch of
people pointed out no Jazz was 20 years
old and living in Florida under Governor
DeSantis getting one of these surgeries
and they're lying and it's the weirdest
thing because they could have won said
nothing two said we are working on it
winky emoji and then oh cool fantastic
instead they went full and attack I
wonder if their actual goal is to make
sure Ron can't actually win
because it's weird how fervent Rhonda
Santa supporters are I got about it's
very weird it's like here's the thing I
don't like about DeSantis and then
they'll just post a whole bunch of lies
about you and start attacking you they
started calling me a grifter because I
was like hey man what's up with this the
reality is I think that Rhonda Santos
knows that if he actually does anything
anything substantive in turn in in
targeting an individual
he'll get annihilated in the Press he
doesn't want it a lot of the stuff that
he has signed comes from the Republic
Republican the Florida Republican
legislature
will Ron be able to actually do anything
with a democrat-controlled congress
the the the real Victory would come in
2024 if the Republicans sweep
good luck they better get on that call
Scott Pressler it's their only it's
their only hope if I can plug
um we will have Scott Pressler as well
as Tucker Carlson will we not be
censoring him Donald Trump myself
Charlie Kirk and Steve Bannon this uh
coming up July 15 16 West Palm Beach
Turning Point action conference Scott
Pressler we've been we've just announced
Turning Point action five million dollar
deal with him just in the state of
Wisconsin directly targeting ballot
harvesting oh wow yeah right on
and that's 5 million just for Wisconsin
they're well I can't say anything yet
but there's discussions of of more Aaron
Tabor says the Deep Floyd model can
generate AI images with legible text
it's already here get ready for fun
times as other models follow suit
I went through my Instagram and I was
showing a skate video to a friend and as
I'm scrolling down I posted a picture
and it said I asked an AI to generate an
image of Nancy Pelosi and here's what it
made and it was the most freakish and
disgusting image and that was the point
but one year ago it could not make a
clear image of Pelosi one year later you
can make an indistinguishable photo of
Nancy Pelosi banging the gavel in in the
in the in Congress those pictures
without you are I mean
if I didn't remember 2020 I think
they're real yeah that's what I think in
the future people will remember those
pictures as being real
right they're gonna say they're gonna
say this the one with him with their
cops pulling him there's gonna be
there's gonna be people who saw that
video and didn't think twice and in six
months they're gonna be like yeah well
you know Trump was all buddy buddy
hugging fouchy and all that because then
they're gonna be like no he didn't I saw
the pictures because because the real
war isn't necessarily over what's on
Twitter or what's on YouTube it's over
memories it's over it's right the
memories of the people who see it and
and so if I can implant an image in your
mind because humans are visual creatures
right a prefrontal cortex everything is
set up for vision
um text is something that came up way
way later so the idea that we are set to
remember all of these images that we see
and be affected by those images that's
why I mean you you were enacting right
you get this
um that uh that is why those images and
the argument I think is a strong one for
being very careful with this
all right if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and become a
member by going to timcast.com and
clicking join us we are about to launch
the members only uncensored portion of
the show you don't want to miss it where
we will have uh many of you calling in
to talk to us and our guests so it'll be
a lot of fun smash the like button
subscribe to this channel you can find
us on Instagram and wherever else at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
everywhere at timcast Brandon you want
to shout anything out
yeah I just want to encourage everyone
to check out our app walk away social we
got off of Facebook now we've moved the
walkway movement to our own apps so you
can load it if you're an Android iPhone
user go to your app store load walk away
social check us out it's awesome
very cool I already mentioned Turning
Point action of course make sure you're
there Tucker Carlson Steve Bannon Donald
J Trump Scott Pressler Jack busovic
Charlie Kirk welcome to be there also my
own show live 2PM every day during the
week and uh keep in mind keep your eyes
open this Thursday Charlie and I have a
little something cooked up uh I'm Ian
Crossland yo you may have saw a sick
sipping on this liquid death it's a
delicious sparkling water and we're not
uh being paid to advertise this stuff
but uh I really like this stuff well
yeah it's because it's metal it's metal
it's not in plastic so we've been you
know how I always rag on plastic and we
got like the glass bottles so uh
we we started buying liquid death for
our bottled water it's canned water so
sweet agave nectar well those are the
flavored ones yeah but like I guess the
company initially was just selling water
in cans yeah I'm like Metals better than
plastic so so it's pretty good Thumbs Up
Guys nice nice product thanks for having
it thanks for getting it yeah what's up
Serge uh yeah that was a good one guys I
appreciate it I appreciate you always
seeing uh seeing you here Brandon um
let's go to this after show okay done we
will see you all over at timcast.com in
about a minute or so thanks for hanging
out